[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5 monde et vos chaînes
tnt en région tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce journal
irons nous vers plus de décentralisation
dans ce journal nous nous rendrons à la
convention annuelle des maires de
provence alpes côte d'azur les maires
qu'ils aimeraient voir élargir leur
champ d'action et leur domaine de
compétence vous verrez dans ce reportage
dans un instant et puis une page
gastronomie dans ce journal des places
100% aveyronnais savourer dans un décor
100% parisien c'est la deuxième édition
d'aveyron en scène une soirée à laquelle
nos caméras ont été conviés ainsi que
nos papilles et puis une étonnante
amitié dans ce journal on vous racontera
l'histoire plutôt surprenante de xavier
qui s'est pris d'amitié pour un pigeon
depuis deux ans ils ne se quittent plus
comme ont pu le constater
nos confrères de tébéo en bretagne
la martinique figure at elle au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco des
experts sont arrivés là bas pour une
visite d'une semaine le but de ce séjour
étudier la candidature du mont pelé et
des pythons de carbes et que vous verrez
dans ce journal
nous débutons ce journal en partant pour
la loire le 25 octobre dernier emmanuel
macron était en déplacement à
saint-etienne et s'est rendu chez si les
ânes une entreprise de robotique
l'occasion pour le président de la
république de revenir sur son plan
france 2030 un plan de financement
massif en direction des nouvelles
technologies écoutez le au micro d'
alice canivez d'adrien bletterie et
d'anthony vers pillon pour tl7 la chaîne
de la loire
mais nous on fonce de l'ue france ont
beau n'être 800 millions d'euros
sur le secteur d'activité kg 400
millions d'euros pour aider la
production pour exactement votre segment
et donc des acteurs de la production de
machines intelligentes de robots avec du
logiciel de l'intelligence artificielle
embarqué pour essayer d'aller faire
encore plus encore mieux gagnant
d'innovation gagny en inventive dans les
trois jours ural eu trop le temps de
l'erreur justement appel qui sera lancé
je vous disais au titre de ce journal le
22 octobre dernier s'est tenu à
marseille la troisième convention
annuelle des mers du sud provence alpes
côte d'azur l'occasion pour renaud
muselier le président de la région de
souligner l'importance du rôle des
maires pour le territoire écoutez le ils
et elles des relations apaisées efficace
et que higuain qui sont nés le vide
inspiration de nos débats évidemment la
question de la décentralisation était
sur toutes les lèvres bruno alberti a
tendu son micro au maire d'antibes et à
la maire du 13e et 14e arrondissement de
marseille qui réclame vous allez le voir
plus de compétences
mais dans la crise sanitaire on a bien
vu qu'on a été seul et que face à une
population qui s'adressait directement
aux maires les maires ont pris des
initiatives
donc qu'ils eurent à la fois ce désarroi
habituel du maire qui se tournent vers
l'état et qui n'a pas de réponse face à
une situation de crise et puis la
capacité des maires de répondre à ses
concitoyens en période de crise je pense
qu'il est important que l'on puisse
parler de décentralisation
un maire de secteur à marseille n'a
quasiment pas de compétences et c'est
assez compliqué pour pouvoir agir au
quotidien puisque les habitants viennent
nous voir pour nous parler de leurs
problèmes et nous ne pouvons pas agir et
puis un autre sujet au coeur des
préoccupations des maires et des
territoires celui des logements
manifestement cela pose quelques
problèmes à roger roux le maire de
beaulieu sur mer écoutez le je suis la
plus petite commune en superficie pour
autant il me manque au titre en série
est pratiquement 300 logements et les
300 logements je ne pourrai jamais
jamais les réaliser et pour autant il
n'ya aucune disposition qui me permette
aux 2,0 g à cette règle cette année a
été trois cents près de 380 mille euros
de pénalités voilà et puis cette
convention attire également de nombreux
acteurs économiques de la région à
l'image de joseph arakel ce chef
d'entreprise marseillais écoutons le je
fais le parallèle avec le chef
d'entreprise le travail qui fournit aux
quotidiennes parlera toutes ces
personnes mais qui n'ont pas des tenants
et les aboutissants dans une entreprise
on peut décider les gens sont contraints
par des lois par des rapports de
situation de force ils ont pas la
maîtrise leurs pouvoirs sont réellement
limité dans le temps qu'il faudrait
qu'ils aient a effectivement peu plus de
décentralisation et tout ce qui est la
relation de proximité soit donnée aux
élus locaux qui connaissent le mieux
leur thé règne des populations tout à
fait autre chose dans l'actualité la
colère gronde au mans la semaine
dernière des manifestants se sont
rassemblés pour dénoncer distille
l'implantation anarchique des éoliennes
dans les campagne sarthoise hélène
galiana de lmtv sarthe les a rencontrés
regarder
journée d'action ce samedi au mans pour
dénoncer les projets éoliens dans le
territoire environ 250 personnes se sont
mobilisées à l'appel de plusieurs
associations locales anti éoliennes et
parmi les manifestants beaucoup d'élus
aussi venus apporter leur soutien
aujourd'hui ce que je voudrais c'est que
aucune installation de soit faite sans
concertation avec le maire et la
population
on ne peut pas détruire nos paysages
quand vous avez la forêt de
sillé-le-guillaume qui est magnifique et
qu'on va mettre à contresens du vent des
éoliennes c'est une aberration pour les
édiles ces constructions qui ont lieu
parfois sans leur concertation préalable
impactent leur commune il ya une
dévaluation immobilière des des maisons
moi sur ma commune y avait des maisons
qui étaient avant il ya des gens qui
avaient commencé à signer un compromis
de vente ils sont venus en arrière quand
ils ont appris il y avait des projets
éoliens donc voilà une délégation a été
reçue pendant plus de deux heures en
préfecture portée par le soutien affiché
du président du conseil départemental de
la sarthe les opposants demandent un
moratoire pour réguler les parcs nous
sommes demandé ce cas là c'est c'est
qu'il ya un moratoire de manière à ce
que hausse pose et que on arrive à
définir déjà dans un premier temps des
critères objectifs pour dire que à tel
endroit
on ne peut pas installer des éoliennes
par exemple il ya plusieurs projets ou
où il ya les pl lui c'est à des plans
locaux d'urbanisme intercommunaux qui
définissent et des zones où ne peut pas
y avoir dix cpe il ya une pression qui
est fait sur les communes pour qu'il y
ait une modification de super lui ils
ont demandé la mise en place de zones de
non éoliens en sarthe pour l'instant
aucune réponse ne leur a été donné sans
transition dans ce journal je vous
propose d'écouter maintenant le
témoignage bouleversant d'une victime
marie une victime de florian de varen
jugé coupable de six viols et d'une
tentative de meurtre tout juste condamné
à 28 ans de réclusion criminelle par la
cour d'assises du tarn et garonne en
attendant les délibérations la jeune
femme s'est confiée à agnès grimaldi nos
confrères sur place de la dépêche
écouter
parce qu il plus difficile c'est qu'on
nous fasse revenir parce qu'il a changé
parce que il va s'expliquer parce que et
puis d'être confronté à un silence
spectaculaire voilà ça c'est difficile
mais après c'est rien par rapport au
fait de ta voix de m 52 lits
nous fait peur enfin faut vraiment être
c'est pas toujours le cas on est face à
quelqu'un à qui est qu
baisser les yeux tout du long
effectivement c'est vrai qu'aux deux
premiers procès il nous regardait mais
avec tellement d'animosité de défiance
de d'arrogance
des sourires narquois effectivement on
est loin de ça
on baisse les yeux parce que c'est peut
être plus facile jusqu'à un regard sage
cash ça se cache pas derrière des
artifices alors voilà
mais non on n'a pas de réponse on
s'est
ainsi lancée dix salles
voilà nous pouvons tous nous trouver en
situation d'avoir à appeler les urgences
sauve life connaissez-vous cette
application créée par un médecin
urgentiste lionel l'amo dont le but est
de pouvoir alerter les utilisateurs les
plus proches lorsqu'une personne est
touché par un arrêt cardiaque et
apporter les gestes de premiers secours
et bien cette application dont se sert
le samu est enfin en service dans la
somme regardez cet exemple dans ce
reportage de jérôme montbron de wéo la
chaîne de la voix du nord
une application smartphone pour sauver
des vies avec sauve life le samu damien
peut désormais alerter les personnes à
proximité d'un accident cardiaque si je
clique tous les toutes les personnes qui
ont l'application s'ouvre là il faut à
mon tour vous recevoir l' alerte en
quelques minutes à peine aidé par la
géolocalisation les détenteurs de
l'application peuvent prendre possession
du défibrillateur le plus proche et se
déplacer sur le lieu de l'accident sur
place les bénévoles peuvent pratiquer le
massage cardiaque épaulé à distance par
les équipes du samu de précieuses
secondes gagnées avant l'arrivée des
secours l'application est opérationnel
depuis trois semaines et on a déjà eu
trois situations où des sauveteurs sont
intervenus on peut pas être partout
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas être à
deux minutes de tout le monde ça on
comprend parfaitement donc ça veut dire
que la possibilité qu'offre sauve live
c'est d'accéder à cette proximité
de moins de 5 minutes de trouver
quelqu'un tout de suite chaque année en
france près de cinquante mille personnes
meurent d'un arrêt cardio respiratoire
des personnes qu un massage cardiaque
aurait peut être sauvé mais voilà
beaucoup considèrent encore ce geste
trop technique et le spa s'agir souvent
dans la peur de mal faire ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre que dans un arrêt
cardiaque le mal faire c'est ne rien
faire il faut agir quoi que vous fassiez
ça sera mieux pour la survie des gens
une minute sans massage carrenet ces 10%
de survie en moins et se courront mètres
en moyenne 14 minutes à arriver vous
comprenez bien qu'il faut donc agir en
france sous live compte déjà cinq cent
trente mille utilisateurs selon
l'association l'application aurait déjà
père mi à ses citoyens sauveteurs de
faire repartir plus de 300 choeurs
sans transition dans ce gîte et
maintenant quand les aveyronnais se met
à table vous allez voir c'est du sérieux
l'aveyron s'est offert comme je vous le
disais dans les titres de ce journal une
opération séduction à paris cette année
c'est la deuxième édition de l'aveyron
en scène qui a mis les petits plats dans
les grands au pied de la tour eiffel
s'il vous plaît et sur une péniche au
programme un menu gastronomique réalisé
par six chefs aveyronnais une occasion
de mettre en avant la qualité de vie les
l'authenticité d'un département qui
gagne à être connu de ce côté là
regardez le meilleur de l'aveyron sur
une péniche c'est le concept original
d'aveyron en scène une soirée événement
qui rassemble les aveyronnais de paris
et d'ailleurs autour d'un repas
gastronomique et dans les assiettes des
400 convives invités un menu 100%
aveyronnais les lentilles de chez nous
le foie gras
le veau de l'aveyron les escargots
proposer la volaille de chez kenta voilà
c'est les fromages du pays et elle est
prêt n'est pas mon si les fruits même le
pen vient de l'aveyron sur le pont c'est
un burger made in aveyron que l'on
prépare avec cette étrange entonnoir le
flambadou on ne chauffe très très fort
est dedans on y insère du lard de pochon
noah qui a trois ans qui font garder sa
forme comme comme du beurre c'est un
rose lavialle certain bout de lard fumé
aux commandes de l'événement serge gélis
de centre-presse le quotidien de
l'aveyron pour qui cette croisière sur
la seine est devenu un lieu de rencontre
et d'échangé incontournable de tous les
aveyronnais il ya trois ans les
aveyronnais de paris la fédération
nationale nous ont sollicités pour
recréer du lien économique et solidaire
entre la capitale où il ya beaucoup
d'aveyronnais et le pays du coup nous
avons recréé un hebdomadaire qui
s'appelle la vie rhône et qui février
les femmes et les hommes de l'aveyron
qui soit à paris ou partout dans le
monde et ensuite on a voulu créer un
événementiel qui est réuni beaucoup de
décideurs économiques
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs et de paris
d'origine aveyronnaise et de l'aveyron
l'occasion également de présenter dans
la capitale un département qui a le vent
en poupe après presque un an et demi de
crise sanitaire un territoire comme le
nôtre il a aujourd'hui un regain presque
mécanique automatique d'attractivité
parce que d'autres français regardent ce
cadre de vie sts qualité de vie avec
envie mais ça ne suffit pas et nous on
veut ne pas se satisfaire de ça avoir
autour de nous tous ces décideurs tous
ces acteurs aveyronnais qu'il vivait en
aveyron qui vive par moments ici à paris
et bien c'est un très grand réconfort
parce que e.on les moyennes de nous
aider à aller au bout de nos ambitions
après deux heures de croisière les
aveyronnais ont déjà pris date pour la
troisième édition toujours en péniche
est toujours sur la scène
voilà qui a dit qu'on ne pourrait pas
tenter des expériences à tous les âges
et qui a dit que la colocation par
exemple n'était faite que pour les
étudiants en réalité la colocation
senior fait de plus en plus d'émules et
apparaît comme une bonne alternative à
la maison de retraite ou à l'ehpad alors
comment cela se passe-t-il entre
colloque du troisième âge c'est ce qu'a
voulu savoir manon touati de 8 mont
blanc en se rendant dans la commune de
le lier au en haute savoie regardez
depuis l'ouverture en juillet de cette
année ils sont sept à vivre ici ils se
retrouvent font des activités ensemble
et partagent même le repas mais
uniquement s'ils le souhaitent
l'objectif est de conserver une
autonomie une liberté totale chaque
résidant à son petit studio avec une
kitchenette il garde donc le contrôle
sur sa vie privée il faut qu'ils soient
acteurs de leur vie il faut qu'ils
participent il faut qu'ils fassent en
fonction de leurs capacités et puis
qu'il retrouve un lien social
aujourd'hui c'est mathieu un des
animateurs qui leur propose une
initiation à la gymnastique douce alter
ballon et vêtements de sport sont de
sortie il vit dans la résidence avec les
seniors et partage son quotidien avec
eux il prend en charge le ménage le
jardin et différentes activités avec sa
compagne margot
l'envi on peut se retrouver aussi bien
sur des temps d'animation que sur des
pans informel des temps vraiment entre
nous mais où on arrive à respecter la
vie enfin la vie de chacun et et voilà
on ne font jamais personne à venir sur
les animations parmi les plus téméraires
aux sports ce matin norbert âgé de 85
ans est l'un des premiers à être arrivés
dans la structure originaire des
yvelines est veuf depuis deux ans il ne
se voyait plus vivre dans une grande
maison tout seul il s'est alors approché
de son fils cadet qui vit à quelques
kilomètres de la résidence est bien ici
je me sens tout à fait décontractée
libéré de toutes les gestions les
sillons immobiliers en payant
dans un milieu où
elle était entourée de famille très
gentil mais très jeune avec des enfants
et j'étais le seul de mon âge
un petit peu gêné d'atteindre sur
tellement d'autres raisons ont poussé
certains se rendre au vallon des voix
bernadette a vécu à abondance et
n'imaginez pas quitter sa région et ses
habitudes elle souhaitait juste
retrouver une nouvelle famille auprès de
ses colocataires c'est vraiment comme
chez nous à part que l'immonde on peut
parler on a plein d'activités le soir la
rangée la soupe ensemble parce que on se
disait tout seul la motivation
c'est bien se retrouve la structure peut
accueillir jusqu'à 24 personnes le coût
total par résident est de 53 euros par
jour mais chacun peut bénéficier dette
de l'état selon ses revenus voilà
direction maintenant gommenec'h dans ce
journal dans les côtes d'armor à la
rencontre d'un autre retraité et d'un
bien beau sujet
xavier lui aussi à un colocataire vous
allez le voir mais un colocataire à
plumes blanches ont c'est son nom est un
pigeon qui partage son quotidien depuis
deux ans avec lui ils racontent leur
étonnante amitié à y revint blonz pour
tébéo la chaîne du couple télérama
bretagne
planches ou bien
allez viens on va travailler xavier
bouger s'adresse à un compagnon
d'ateliers très particulier blanchon une
femelle pigeons de deux ans est devenu
l'oiseau de compagnie pour ce retraité
il prend part à ma vie il prend part à
mes occupations
tout ce que l'on peut faire dans une
journée et puis
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on s'entend
bien leur lumière leurs chants bien tous
les deux sont inséparables et vont même
jusqu'à partager la monture pour des
balades en vélo l'histoire d'amour
commence il ya deux ans quand xavier
trouve sur le bord de la route cet
oiseau affaiblis ils étaient tous des
plumes et dans les allées de boules puis
il a dit la lettre la proie des la proie
des chats les ramener avec moi dans ma
poche et je les mets dans mon atelier un
petit peu plus loin là bas un bout de
trois semaines un mois il a commencé à
se faire c'est elle c'est à ce moment là
que j'ai pris la décision d'ouvrir la
porte de mon atelier si tu veux partir
tu pars si tu es bien avec moi tu restes
et depuis lé là une relation étonnante
mais aussi exclusif difficile pour
marie-françoise qui est pourtant la
femme de xavier d'approché l'oiseau sans
prendre un coup de bec en jeu en seconde
position ce pas parce que tout est sur
blanc chaud ou pour pas à faire s'il
faut pas faire attention alors au monde
on partait ce premier tour et dimanche
quelque part maintenant si si on ne
réussit pas à entrer l'écoutent et il
faut partir vite et rentrez vite l'api
jon est devenu le centre des attentions
et son histoire s'est écrite à travers
le monde dans plus de 180 pays ce petit
pigeon se trouvait sur mon sur mon
passage un jour je les ramasse et parce
que j'aime les animaux et le reste ça
s'est fait tout seul blanchon et xavier
continueront de vivre leur relation
exceptionnelle sans jamais tenter l'un
comme l'autre de s'apprivoiser voilà je
vous l'annoncé dans les titres la
montagne pelée les pitons du carbet en
martinique pourraient bientôt être
classé au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
les avant de rendre leur verdict en
juillet prochain les experts de
l'organisation sont allés sur place se
rendre compte de la splendeur et des
merveilles de la région diana françois
eudoxie et loïc régis de atv martinique
était évidemment du voyage regarder
embarquement immédiat pour une
découverte des trésors du nord
l'exploration côtière offre une vue
imprenable sur la montagne pelée et les
pitons du carbet la mission est menée
par des agents du parc naturel régional
de la martinique à compagnie de deux
experts en volcanologie et biosphère
objectif jugé les atouts géologique de
notre territoire la montagne pelée c'est
un volcan qui représente un cas unique
et c'est pour ça qu'on considère donc il
a une valeur universelle c'est le cas
pour les projets donc dans le camp des
postes dans le monde dans le classement
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco il
faut une valeur universelle et alors
cette cette montagne père a une valeur
universelle simplement à cause de
l'éruption de 1902 pascal a produit des
explosions su très superficielle à la
base du dom et qui sont qui ont été
dirigées horizontalement la plupart des
éruptions s'est dirigé vers qui calment
observé depuis le littoral la grande
dame domine la côte caraïbe autour
d'elle une multitude de trésors comme
séance accessible uniquement en bateau 2
il est au large du prêcheur ou encore
ces cavités rocheuses une immersion au
plus près pour les deux experts mandatés
par l'unesco tu es c'est pour ça qu'on a
organisées donc 7 7 7 7 sessions d'une
semaine justement pour avec ses experts
et avec un certain nombre de
spécialistes et puis de ceux qui ont
préparé le projet justement pour les
leur expliquer tout ce qu'on a fait tout
ce qui a été vu il donc le leur montrer
le bleu le caractère universel donc de
nos biens le dossier porté par la france
a toutes ses chances car ces richesses
sont nombreuses un des points phares
le rocher la perle lille est la perle
voilà qui on va dire d'hommes volcanique
1 au même titre que le rocher du diamant
dès que nous avons donc c'est la commune
du prêcheur nous avons des sites de
nidification d'oiseaux et avec tout ce
dont nico système marin assez riche avec
des récifs coralliens des herbiers des
populations de poissons et des
mammifères marins une visite d'une
semaine pour placer définitivement la
montagne pelée et les pitons du carbet
parmi les joyaux incontesté de ce monde
voilà des monts martinique et aux
montagnes vosgiennes cela ne vous a pas
échappé nous sommes en plein milieu des
vacances scolaires
alors je vous emmène maintenant prendre
un grand bol d'air car les massifs
vosgiens ont visiblement la cote cette
année comme nous l'expliquent louise
hamouda and didier et nicholas bray
d'art pour vosges télévision sur place
ils affluent depuis ce week-end nouvelle
preuve de l'attractivité de notre
département ça y est les vacances de la
toussaint ont commencé et sur le massif
comme ici à gérardmer ce lundi les
touristes eux retrouvent les sentiers
sur les hauteurs de la ville ce jeune
photographe et vidéaste est venu
chercher la nature la faune la flore
morsure c'est là les bruits ambiants
dormir d'un véhicule monbana ménagé
depuis mon enfance en fait je viens ici
du coup je me retrouve en fait pour l'un
photo pour la créativité mon inspiration
tout simplement d'autres se contentent
de profiter de la météo très favorable
et du grand air on peut de randonnée on
la prendrait un peu des vosges et puis à
visite à nos amis qu'est ce que vous
aimez dans le coin
l'apéro chez mes amis non non les belles
balades de la forêt tous avouent même si
on vient dé haute savoie c'est pas c'est
pas pareil c'est pas la même montagne on
a la chance d'avoir un très beau temps
et puis la région est magnifique de la
khl à la forêt les promenades enfin
c'est une ressource une ressource de vie
quoi côté logement l'office de tourisme
de gérardmer observe une hausse de la
fréquentation pour la période des
vacances plus de la moitié des meublés
du secteur ont trouvé preneurs ces 7 %
de plus qu'en 2019 les hôtels sont
quasiment pleins les week-ends en
semaine il ya pas mal de champs et sur
les meublés de tourisme donc je disais
au niveau de notre centrale de
réservation on est sur des taux
supérieurs à l'an dernier d'environ 2 3%
selon les professionnels la destination
vosges pourrait également profiter de la
hausse du prix des carburants auprès
d'une clientèle à la recherche d'un
tourisme de proximité pas trop coûteux
seule baisse c'est l'affluence des
touristes des pays voisins il
représentait cet été 25 % des
réservations contre 18% cet automne les
perspectives hivernale elles sont
encourageantes l'office de tourisme
enregistre déjà des réservations pour
les prochains mois et puis regardez ces
images non vous ne rêvez pas c'est bien
une écharpe de 3350 six mètres qui a été
tricotée par mille personnes pendant
deux ans qui a été déployé sur le pont
de saint nazaire comme vous le voyez sur
ces images prises par bea balti de
télénantes nos confrères sur place
l'objectif récolter des fonds pour le
téléthon et la recherche sur les
maladies génétiques rares
le téléthon qui rappelons le aura lieu
le 3 décembre prochain
voilà après quatre jours de compétition
15 épreuves 350 km de course le
cinquième ira lee de monte carlo s'est
achevée le 24 octobre dernier par la
victoire de deux français frédéric
l'audio et nicolas beau duo sur
volkswagen id4 un rallye où nos concours
que des voitures 100% électriques et
hydrogène dont vous voyez quelques
images ici signé vanessa décide de
monaco info
nous avons tous de plus en plus
conscience de la qualité de l'air que
nous devons respirer pour mieux vivre et
bien saviez vous que l'air intérieur est
5 à 10 fois plus pollué que celui de
l'extérieur l'explication d'emilie palka
ingénieurs d'etudes che atm au une
association qui surveille la qualité de
l'air en nouvelles aquitaine des propos
recueillis par bene dodo un de télé7 du
groupe sud ouest sur place
les pôles et on est à l'intérieur ça va
être tout ce qui est mobilier peinture
moquette et sert à tout ça va émettre
des polluants il ya également
les habitudes des occupants
si les personnes fument si on utilise
des bougies de l'ensemble par exemple à
tout ça ça va apporter des polluants à
l'intérieur du logement et puis quelques
images dans ce journal de l'ouverture
jeudi dernier à médan dans les yvelines
de la maison d'emile zola une
réouverture après dix ans de travaux on
peut voir le bureau de l'écrivain ici
sur les images de nicolas landry de télé
78 et puis juste à côté toujours dans
les yvelines a été inauguré un nouveau
musée consacré à alfred dreyfus cet
ancien officier français de confession
juive victime en 1894 d'une machination
judiciaire
voilà on finit ce journal en musique
celle de pacte gaulois un film sorti
l'année dernière son compositeur le
talentueux julien cuvillier ce que l'on
voit sur ces images de briangaud requis
pour la chaîne tébéo la chaîne groupe le
télégramme vient de décrocher le prix de
la meilleure musique au concours de la
chaîne archéologique de los angeles de
cette musique
[Musique]
voilà quand la musique bretonne part à
la conquête d'hollywood c'est la fin de
ce grand jt des territoires merci de
nous avoir suivi sur vos chaînes de la
tnt en région et sur tv5 monde on se
retrouve pour une prochaine édition aura
tout ce que mon corps alors
[Musique]